[Applaus]
es ist so passiert dass der beginn des
einsatzes
zufällig zusammen viel mit einem unser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so das ist jetzt ein wenig irritierend
denn mitten in der rede von wladimir
putin hat das staatsfernsehen offenbar
noch einmal zurückgespult und ist jetzt
noch mal auf den teile zurückgegangen wo
eben dieser russische sänger aufgetreten
ist das ganze etwa von einer halben
stunde ob es da jetzt ein leitungs
problem gab was dahintersteckt können
wir im moment tatsächlich nicht sagen
aber doch eine recht ungewöhnlicher
vorgang muss man sagen es werden weiter
jeden
jubelnde massen gezeigt allerdings hatte
man ja nun extra auf diese rede von
wladimir putin gewartet der ja nun auch
sogar persönlich ins stadion gekommen
ist und eben da an sein volk zu sprechen
um die russen noch einmal einzuschwören
ja und wohl auch um seine lügen über die
sogenannte militär operation in der
ukraine zu verbreiten die wir ja nun
wissentlich eben als krieg bezeichnen
als nichts anderes was es eben ist
also lass mir diese bilder noch ein
wenig auf und wirken es ist tatsächlich
ein etwas merkwürdiger moment wir können
jetzt ihnen auch keine weiteren
informationen wirklich über den grund
dieses ausfalls gegeben nochmal zur
erklärung wir waren gerade mitten in der
rede von wladimir putin als das
russische staatsfernsehen selbst also
das haben wir jetzt umgeschaltet
tatsächlich nochmal zurückgespult hat
jetzt und plötzlich ebenbilder einspielt
die schon eine ganze weile her sind wir
können uns das momentan nicht wirklich
erklären ob es da irgend einen
zwischenfall gegeben hat ob es zu einem
technischen zwischenfall gegeben hat
jetzt bleiben sie eben weiter auf diesen
fahnen schwenkenden massen und
wiederholen daneben auch noch mal die
auftritte der verschiedenen künstler der
linientreuen putin treuen künstler die
ebenso zahlreich da eine geladene boden
das luschniki-stadion sehr befremdliche
bilder muss man natürlich sagen wenn wir
den ganzen tag eben diese dramatischen
bilder aus der ukraine sehen und dann
diese wirkliche zynische
veranstaltungen in moskau wir wollen mal
mit dem kollegen philipp potthoff
sprechende philipp du hast dir diese
veranstaltung jetzt auch mit angeschaut
kannst du dir erklären was da passiert
ist warum da jetzt das signal von
wladimir putin plötzlich weg ist warum
man da wieder zurück gespielt hat und
jetzt auf alte material sozusagen sendet
also wenn das russische staatsfernsehen
tatsächlich eine büttenrede unterbricht
um altes material zu zeigen dann bietet
das material für derart wilde
spekulation dass ich sie lieber gar
nicht erst aussprechen möchte
diese ganze veranstaltung ist auf jeden
fall total bizarr und sie widerspricht
doch eigentlich den kern der russischen
propaganda das finde ich ganz
interessant denn eigentlich ist in
russland sei nur die rede von einer
spezialoperation aber es werden
kriegslieder gezogen es werden lieder
gesungen den die rede und krieg ist und
das könnte ja ein mann der anderen
russen zu denken geben warum der
staatsapparat eigentlich nicht zum krieg
reden will aber hier kriegslieder
aufgeführt werden und putin selbst die
er sätze die man gehört hat das war die
klassische oper kann der lüge dass hier
ein genozid verübt wurde den russland
aufgehalten habe interessanterweise hat
gut wie noch kein einziges opfer dieses
genozids gezeigt aber offenbar sind die
russen bereit das zu glauben und ja was
den fortgang dieser rede und auch ihrer
übertragung angeht da müssen wir jetzt
auf die russen warten